you know you started a company at 21
years old which was called what happy
happy or something like that it was
earlier yeah
it not too that he was in you were 21
years old maybe even younger than yeah
19 years old and you got all the way up
to i don't know i saw some of the apps
together 10 million downloads on apple
ios and then eventually cops showed up
knocking on your door saying
tell us the story with what happened
with that
technology
well that was a long time ago but when
i was a kid i was loving um
programming right i was obsessed with
computers so i would stay home from high
school and watch mit video lectures on
computer programming and so that was my
outlet that's how i learned a lot of
things and my
family kind of indulged that they let me
do it uh and when i was younger i was
like oh this is uh silicon valley san
francisco is a place where a lot of
startup companies happen in australia
where i grew up it wasn't as cool to do
a startup and i was still still 2007 so
i went to visit just to see what it was
like and i met some great people
who ended up being investors and in 07
it was some of the first facebook apps
so you make quiz games and all these
different games that people would play
and it was really cool because i got to
do the thing i like to do which is
create stuff so i'm very creative i love
programming i love designing things and
so that was a great outlet for that it
was kind of entrepreneurial part was
secondary to it um and yeah made a lot
of things that were viral and same when
the iphone first came out made a lot of
top iphone games so in total we had like
20 or 30 different games and different
apps and along the way um all kinds of
stuff happened yeah got it so if i was
in high school with you 10th grade 11th
grade who were you in high school
i was pretty quiet i had like a guy with
like two or three friends you were the
quiet kid yeah you were you were genius
you were smart you knew what you were
doing with coding building stuff yeah
but i was more independent right so
sometimes i wouldn't get the best grades
because i just love to do my own thing
a little bit
anti-authoritarian right
like
some you know to get me to do something
you tell me not to do it like half the
time yeah then i would be interested in
it but if there was too much pressure
i'd say you know what what's the point
you know so then you know what that
makes me think about it it makes me
think about
um you know for me so i'm uh
i'm big on capitalism right i'm big on
free enterprise free market so then you
go deeper and you say why well i was
raised in iran so who cares what does
that have to do with capitalism raising
iran i won free speech
every time i said something i got in
trouble
and then i come to america i want to
make the kind of money i want to make i
don't want you to stop me from doing it
and other people are trying to tell me
what to do control me regulation all
this other stuff it led me to want to
start a company with the mission
statement of bringing back the free
enterprise system and hope to american
families right that's what drove me
to start a company like clearvue ai
you can wake up and do many different
things if you know how to code you can
decide to compete against a twitter and
create a twitter
using uh cryptocurrency and blockchain
technology and go a different route
there's many different routes why
did you choose to build something like
clearview ai where's the motive for that
yeah it's a great question and it's very
interesting what you said about free
enterprise and things like that i think
it's very important and i think what
makes america great is it can take
people who are a little rebellious and
channel that energy into making really
great companies and providing value so i
think uh the us as a as a system as an
entrepreneurial system uh gets really
gets the best out of people and that's
what's really impressive about it even
when you compare it to other you know
western countries but what came my
motivation's always been technology so
again when i was a kid
mit had their video lectures on lisp and
scheme programming which was very
esoteric stuff which i loved and so i
was always looking at different
programming languages and how to build
things and then when i was in san
francisco i ended up moving to new york
city traveling around and i had a fair
amount of spare time i didn't really
know what to do and part of the time i
was looking at the advances in ai so i
saw imagenet which is a competition for
recognizing things in images is this a
computer is this a plant is this a dog
or a cat and the results got really good
and then i looked at facial recognition
and i would read papers so google had
facebook both had deep learning papers
on facial recognition i said hey can i
get this working on my computer and we
ended up getting it working and what we
realized was getting more data to train
the algorithm to make it accurate across
all ethnicities iranian people black
people white people brown people that
was really key to improving performance
uh and so it was really tinkering around
and seeing that there was a big gap
there it was great to get it working and
then it was next step was finding use
cases i mean i never thought i'd be
selling to law enforcement be honest
right 3100 agents yeah plus yeah and um
so
what happened was we made this really
great technology and we were pitching
different ideas would it work for
building access would it work for you
know hospitality the iphone just came
out with uh face id would it work for
and and there was some demand there
people liked it but when we gave it to
law enforcement they came back the next
week and said we got like 20 cases we
solved
and then we came in we looked at looked
at them and sometimes
they didn't even look that similar but
it was the same guy and so these were
cash out scams so people would say hey
my name is
joe smith and my social is blah blah i
need a new debit card or i need to
withdraw you know ten thousand dollars
in cash and the teller would say hey
show me your id and the id would have
their face and all the information and
so for the first time they were able to
take the face of the criminal who
impersonated someone else and find them
on social media
on a previous arrest and that was
phenomenal the next week they called up
and said we've identified a
person who's been talking to a 12 year
old girl so that kind of like impact was
much better than anything else we could
have thought of did you think about that
pre-starting the company like let me go
catch the bad guy or is it more
let's find a better way to
you know
create a company that's not out there
because you know it's sometimes guys sit
around the smartest guys in silicon
valley will sit around and sit around
and say you know like the paypal mafia
you know um uh let's go compete in this
market we can beat them and we just use
a blue ocean strategy you know minimize
increase decrease eliminate you know
create all this that's what we're going
to do let's go after this industry let's
go after that industry was it one of
those things where you and your friends
sat there and said how about if we go
after these guys or was it somebody a
bad guy did something to you and your
family said i'm gonna go go catch every
one of these bad guys ever what was the
motivation
the original motive again is technology
and making it work so once we got it to
work islamic technology it was amazing
we and once we found law enforcement as
would you understand what i'm asking yes
so business strategy is part of it but i
don't have as much of a business
background as a tech background right so
uh once we've figured out law
enforcement's there it's very clear
there's a lot of agencies you can make a
lot of money but there's no other
motivation like there wasn't like a
correcting in injustice catching a bad
guy you know it's
well there's definitely a lot of crime
in san francisco nothing personal okay
but uh i mean i lived in san francisco
for eight years and it's definitely
declined ever since i when i left i
didn't think it could get any worse so
what's important to me is things that
are in the public interest right so
uh you know living in new york city was
kind of
great because there was more than one
subway line things worked a lot better
and i got to meet a lot of people who
used to be in new york city government
and were
and i think that they're fantastic
especially people in the nypd so
we're always thinking
about
it's very
when you're starting something new right
it can be very nebulous right especially
if you have a technology but the theme
of facial recognition if there was a
theme to it it's about safety and
security right you can unlock your phone
with facial recognition uh
id checks are done with facial
recognition these are all things done in
an opt-in way and then you also have
something like clearview which can be
also for safety which is searching a
database uh to identify someone who's
unknown
right so we're always thinking about
safety and security we never even though
i spent my
earlier part of my career doing consumer
internet we couldn't really think of a
use case there another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]